NATION ARE CALLING ON
GOVERNORS TO ROLL BACK
STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS.
JILLIAN: THOUSANDS DEMANDING
THEIR STATES EASE RESTRICTIONS
SO THEY CAN GET BACK TO WORK.
GOVERNORS NOW UNVEILING PLANS TO
LIFT LOCKDOWN ORDERS.
IN FLORIDA SOME BEACHES REOPENED
WITH SOCIAL DISTANCING
GUIDELINES.
GRIFF: TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT SAYS HE PLANS TO REOPEN
STATE PARKS ON MONDAY AND REOPEN
RETAIL BUSINESSES FOR PICKUP,
DELIVERY AND MAIL ORDERS NEXT
FRIDAY.
INTERESTING DEVELOPMENTS THERE.
SO WE WANT TO GO AHEAD AND BRING
IN CONGRESSMAN DAN CRENSHAW
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE HOMELAND
SECURITY AND FORMER NAVY SEAL
AUTHOR OF FORT FORTITUDE
AMERICAN RESILIENCE IN THE ERA
OF OUTRAGE CONGRESSMAN GOOD
MORNING TO YOU TELL ME ABOUT
WHAT’S HAPPENING DOWN THERE IN
TEXAS.
>> WELL WE’RE DOING WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING WHICH IS A
STAGED REOPENING AND YOU
MENTIONED EXACTLY WHAT GOVERNOR
ABBOTT DECLARED AND WE’LL HAVE
MORE ANNOUNCEMENTS OF WHAT IS
OPEN BY APRIL 27 AND ANOTHER
THING I’D ADD TO THAT LIST WHICH
IS REALLY IMPORTANT IS ALLOWING
MORE SURGERIES AND PROCEDURES TO
TAKE PLACE IN OUR HOSPITALS.
OUR HOSPITALS ARE EMPTY RIGHT
NOW, AND DOCTORS ARE PUTTING OFF
IMPORTANT SURGERIES.
THESE AREN’T NOSE JOBS WE’RE
TALKING ABOUT.
MY OWN FATHER HAD TROUBLE
GETTING INTO GET HEART STENT IN
PLACE, SO THIS IS SOME COMMON
SENSE STUFF THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
I HOPE TEXAS CAN LEAD THE WAY
AND DEMONSTRATE HOW THIS NEEDS
TO GO FOR THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
JILLIAN: CONGRESSMAN YOU’RE
RIGHT MY MOM IS THE DIRECTOR OF
NURSING AT A SURGERY CENTER IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND THEY AREN’T
EVEN DOING ELECTIVE SURGERIES
AND A LOT OF ELECTIVE SURGERIES,
THEY ARE STILL VERY IMPORTANT TO
PEOPLE, AND THEIR HEALTH, THAT’S
THE  UT MOST IMPORTANCE TO THEM
RIGHT NOW.
>> 100%.
THERE’S ANOTHER PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERN WHEN WE START TO CLOSE
HOSPITALS, AND WHEN WE ALLOW THE
ECONOMY TO CONTINUE TO FAT
TER, AND WE HAVE TO KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THAT AND THAT HAS
TO BE PART OF THE BALANCED
DISCUSSION ON HOW WE LIVE SIDE
BY SIDE WITH COVID-19, WHAT
WITHIN AN OPEN ECONOMY.
WE CAN TAKE RISK MITIGATION
MEASURES WHILE GETTING BACK TO
SOME SENSE OF NORMALCY, THAT’S
WHAT WE’RE DOING HERE IN TEXAS
AND THE WHOLE COUNTRY CAN FOLLOW
SUIT.
PETE: CONGRESSMAN WE’RE IN A
MOMENT OF FEDERALISM AND PEOPLE
ARE WAKING UP LOOKING AT THEIR
STATE GOVERNMENTS AND GOVERNORS
AND THE WAY THEY VIEW THE WORLD
IN NEW JERSEY, PHIL MURPHY SAID
THAT THE BILL OF RIGHTS, HE
WASN’T THINKING ABOUT IT WHEN HE
WAS MAKING THESE CALLS.
WHAT’S YOUR MESSAGE TO GOVERNORS
AS THEY MAKE THESE DECISIONS AS
IT PERTAINS TO THE FIRST
RIGHTS OF AMERICAN CITIZENS?
>> FIRST OF ALL TAKE A CIVICS
CLASS YOU SHOULD ALWAYS BE
LOOKING AT THE BILL OF RIGHTS
AND ALSO, UNDERSTAND WHICH LAWS
ARE RESPECTABLE AND WHICH ONES
AREN’T.
PEOPLE WILL NOT FOLLOW AND
RESPECT LAWS THAT ARE NOT
RESPECTABLE THEMSELVES.
USE SOME COMMON SENSE.
OKAY?
YOU SAW IN MICHIGAN WHERE
THEY’RE SECTIONING OFF GARDENING
SUPPLIES IN AN OPEN STORE.
I MEAN, COME ON.
THIS IS NONSENSE.
OF COURSE PEOPLE AREN’T GOING TO
RESPECT THAT.
THESE GOVERNORS HAVE TO THINK
THROUGH, WHAT IS THE CONNECTION
TO STOPPING THE SPREAD WITH
THEIR NEW LAW.
IT’S A VERY SIMPLE QUESTION, BUT
THEY AREN’T THINKING THROUGH IT,
AND VOTERS SHOULD HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN YOUR LT.
GOVERNOR DAN PATRICK IS HOLDING
YOU, MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
ACCOUNTABLE, SAYING THAT YOU
NEED TO GET BACK TO WORK AND
POSSIBLY TAKE A PAY CUT.
HERE IS WHAT HE HAD TO SAY TO
LAURA INK GRAHAM.
>> I’M REALLY TIRED OF NANCY
PELOSI AND CONGRESS BECAUSE THEY
, YOU KNOW WHAT THEY’RE NOT
HURT BY THIS.
THEY ARE AT HOME DOING NOTHING
IT’S TIME FOR THEM TO GET BACK
TO WORK AND QUITE FRANKLY I
THINK THEY NEED TO TAKE A HALF
PAY CUT, TEXAS, WE MAKE OUR
SENATORS AND OUR HOUSE MEMBERS
AND MYSELF MAKE $600 A MONTH.
WE WORK 50 HOURS A WEEK WITH THE
TENTH LARGEST ECONOMY, WE
MEET EVERY YEAR, WE’RE A
VOLUNTEER PUBLIC VERSE AND IT’S
TIME FOR CONGRESS TO TAKE A PAY
CUT SO THEY FEEL SOME OF THIS
PAIN THAT PEOPLE AT HOME
ARE FEELING, BECAUSE CONGRESS
ISN’T FEELING ANY PAIN.
THE PEOPLE IN THE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE, GET BACK TO WORK
AND CUT YOUR PAY, AND SHOW THAT
YOU’RE WITH US.
GRIFF: DAN YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
DO YOU AGREE?
>> HE’S HALF RIGHT, WE DO NEED
TO GET BACK TO WORK AND GET THIS
PPP PROGRAM ABSOLUTELY
UP AND RUNNING I’D REMIND MY
FRIEND DAN THAT NOT ALL OF US
HAVE $24,000 REFRIGERATORS LIKE
NANCY PELOSI.
SO I UNDERSTAND WHERE HE’S
COMING FROM HE’S ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
WE’VE GOT TO GET BACK TO WORK,
NOT ALL MEMBERS OF CONGRESS CAME
INTO CONGRESS WITH A BUNCH OF
MONEY SO LET ME REMIND HIM OF
THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
JILLIAN: LET’S GO PARENT HEAD
AND TALK ABOUT YOUR NEW BILL
THAT WOULD ALLOW AMERICANS TO
SUE CHINA OVER COVID-19.
TELL US DETAILS ABOUT THIS.
>> RIGHT SO AS WE SEE
INCREASING EVIDENCE THAT THE
CHINESE AUTHORITIES, THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY HID
THIS VIRUS DELIBERATELY, ALLOWED
DOMESTIC TRAVEL, OR  RESTRICTED
DOMESTIC TRAVEL IN CHINA BUT
ALLOWED INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL
FROM WUHAN DISAPPEAR THESE
SCIENTISTS AND DOCTORS WHO BLEW
THE WHISTLE WOULDN’T ALLOW OUR
JOURNALISTS IN AND SAMPLES OF
THE VIRUS TO BE SHARED IT’S AN
INCREASING AMOUNT OF EVIDENCE
THAT SHOWS THEY ARE CULPABLE.
SO WHAT CAN WE DO ABOUT THAT?
WELL WHEN AMERICANS ARE WRONG
WHAT DO WE DO?
WE SUE SOMEBODY.
WELL LET’S LET AMERICANS SUE THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT, SO THIS
BILL WOULD SIMPLY CHANGE
THE FOREIGN SOVREIGN IMMUNITY
ACT SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY DO
THAT IN OUR COURTS, NOW WE WOULD
DO IT IN THE SELECT FEW COURTS
SO THAT IT DOESN’T OF COURSE
OVERWHELMING, AND WE THINK THIS
BE A GREAT WAY FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO SEEK
DAMAGES AGAINST THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
PETE: I THINK IT’S A GREAT IDEA.
WHAT OTHER THINGS SHOULD OUR
GOVERNMENT BE DOING AS WE HAVE
THIS UNFORTUNATE MOMENT OF
EXPOSURE OF THE EVIL OF THIS
COMMUNIST REGIME.
WHAT MORE CAN WE DO TO STARE
THEM DOWN, TAKE THEM DOWN?
>> YEAH, THIS IS A LOT OF
THINGS AND A LOT OF POLITICAL
WILL TO DO THAT.
IT JUST BECOMES A TECHNICAL
DISCUSSION.
ANOTHER BILL THAT I’VE PROPOSED
WOULD NOT ALLOW CHINESE OFFICIAL
S TO ENGAGE IN
PROPAGANDA DURING THE PANDEMIC
TO BE ALLOWED INTO THE UNITED
NATIONS AND NEW YORK CITY, AND
WE HAVE TO START DUSTING OFF
SOME OTHER OLD CHINESE POLICIES
TOO TALKING ABOUT PROTECTING OUR
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY FROM
CHINESE THEFT, JUST PROTECTING
OUR SUPPLY CHAINS, BRINGING
THOSE BACK HOME FOR CORE
MANUFACTURING THAT WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED IN THIS COUNTRY.
THIS IS A CONVERSATION THAT WAS
HAPPENING LONG BEFORE THIS
CRISIS, BUT I THINK THIS
CRISIS SHOWS US THAT WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH A LOT
OF THESE POLICIES.
JILLIAN: I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY
HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU THAT WE
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
ABLE TO GET ALL OF THE ANSWERS
THAT WE NEED FROM CHINA AS TO
HOW THIS ALL STARTED, AS TO HOW
IT WAS ABLE TO ESCAPE AND
PENETRATE THE ENTIRE WORLD?
DO YOU FEEL CONFIDENT WE’LL GET
THE ANSWERS WE NEED?
>> WELL I FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
WE NEED AN INVESTIGATION TO DO
THAT.
SENATOR HOLLY, CONGRESSMAN STEFA
NIC HAVE PUT
LEGISLATION FORWARD THAT WOULD
REQUIRE AN INTERNATIONAL
INVESTIGATION AND OF COURSE THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY IS
ALWAYS GOING TO LIE AND TRY TO
COVER FOR THEMSELVES THAT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING, BUT THAT DOESN’T
MEAN WE CAN’T SEEK OUT THE TRUTH
THERE ARE A LOT OF OPPRESSED
PEOPLE IN CHINA, AND I BET THEY
WANT THAT WORD TO GET OUT AND
THE TRUTH ALREADY IS COMING OUT
SO THAT’S WHY SENATOR COTTON AND
I, HE PROPOSED THIS ON THE
SENATE SIDE.
THIS IS MY BILL ON THE HOUSE
SIDE.
THAT’S WHY WE DID THIS.
WE WANT AMERICANS TO FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE A VOICE, AND THAT OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM CAN BE USED TO
ACTUALLY DELIVER JUSTICE FOR US.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN, I GOT TO GET
TO THIS BECAUSE IT’S OUT
THERE, AND MANY OF US SAW IT OR
CLIPS YOU WERE ON WITH BILL
MOORE LAST NIGHT, AND COMMENTS
MAKING THE ROUNDS TELL US WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> WELL, A LOT HAPPENED OF
COURSE THEY MAKE IT ALL ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP BUT LISTEN, THE
NARRATIVE I’VE SEEN OF LATE
IS THIS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
BLOOD ON HIS HANDS THAT THEY
DIDN’T DO ANYTHING THAT THEY
DENIED THE WHOLE THING AND
THAT’S JUST NOT FACTUALLY
CORRECT.
I’VE CREATED VIDEOS ON THIS ,
WE’VE BEEN VERY VOCAL I PUT THIS
OUT IN PODCASTS AND WE NEED
TO GET THE TRUTH OUT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND WHEN I WAS
ON BILL’S SHOW HE THOUGHT THE
SAME THING, SO I JUST HAD TO
STOP HIM AND SAY LOOK, LIKE AT
EVERY POINT IN YOUR TIMELINE
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS HAPPENING
THAT YOU’RE LEAVING OUT AND WE
JUST POINT THOSE THINGS OUT.
I LIKE CHATTING WITH BILL
BECAUSE IT’S JUST A GOOD DEBATE,
FRANKLY, AND I FEEL IT’S
NECESSARY FOR CONSERVATIVES TO
GO ON SHOWS LIKE THAT AND TALK
ABOUT THESE THINGS.
WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT ELECTIONS
AND WAITING IN LINES AND I HAD
TO CORRECT THE RECORD ON THAT.
THERE’S SO MANY MISCONCEPTIONS
OUT THERE THAT THE LEFT JUST
BELIEVES AND THEY JUST REPEAT IT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN SO THEY JUST
START TO THINK THOSE THINGS ARE
TRUE, SO IT’S UP TO US TO
ACTUALLY SAY HEY, LET’S CONFRONT
THIS DIRECTLY THIS ISN’T TRUE
HERE IS THE CONTEXT AND HERE IS
THE ACTUAL FACTS AND I LOVE
DOING IT.
IT WAS FUN.
PETE: GOOD STUFF I CAN’T WAIT TO
CHECK OUT THE ENTIRE THING BUT
YOU TALK ABOUT GOING ON THE
OFFENSE NOT LETTING
NARRATIVES FALSE CONTINUE.
YOU WROTE AN OP-ED ENTITLED
TACTICAL RETREAT FROM COVID-19
MADE SENSE, NOW LET’S GO BACK ON
OFFENSE AND MOBILIZE.
WHAT’S THE MOST CRITICAL THING
RIGHT NOW THAT WE SHOULD DO ON
OFFENSE?
>> WELL WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS
WE HAVE TO LIVE WITH THIS TRUTH
THAT WE SIMPLY HAVE TO OPEN UP
OUR ECONOMY AND LIVE SIDE-BY-
SIDE WITH THE RISKS OF
COVID-19.
NOW WE CAN DO THIS SAFELY, BUT
THERE’S NOT THIS BINARY CHOICE
BETWEEN PERPETUAL LOCKDOWN AND
ACTUALLY LETTING PEOPLE DIE.
THAT’S NOT THE CHOICE.
WE CAN RISK MITIGATE AND YOU DO
IT ALONG THREE FACTORS RAMPING
UP TESTING WHICH WE ARE DOING
RAPIDLY.
RAMPING UP HOSPITAL CAPACITY
WHICH WE HAVE DONE RAPIDLY
THAT’S VENTILATOR PRODUCTION, PP
E PRODUCTION
MAKING SURE WE HAVE SECTIONS OF
HOSPITALS THAT ARE STILL
DESIGNATED FOR COVID-19 PATIENTS
, AND THIRD, PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
THE PUBLIC IS WELL EDUCATED AT
THIS POINT.
I THINK PEOPLE CAN TAKE SOME
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY, WEAR A
CLOTH MASK GET BACK TO WORK,
MAINTAIN SIX FOOT SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND IT’S A NEW NORMAL
, BUT WE CAN MAKE THIS
HAPPEN, EVERY SINGLE
BUSINESS, EVERY SINGLE
RESTAURANT CAN LIVE WITHIN THIS
NEW NORMAL.
WE HAVE TO START TRUSTING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE TO
START EMPOWERING THEMSELVES WITH
THE PROPER TOOLS TO RISK
MITIGATE.
I THINK THAT’S WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE AND THAT’S WHAT OFFENSE
LOOKS LIKE.
PETE: WELL SAID TRUSTING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THAT’S BEEN
THE PREMISE OF OUR EXPERIMENT,
THE ENTIRE TIME.
CONGRESSMAN DAN CRENSHAW THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR INSIGHT